eso está dando la vuelta al mundo son
hipersónicos su velocidad es cinco veces
mayor a la del sonido y alcanzan
objetivos de forma precisa a dos mil
kilómetros el ministerio de defensa
informó que por segundo día consecutivo
fueron utilizados este domingo
los misiles de crucero lanzados desde el
mar caspio y desde el espacio aéreo
sobre el territorio de crimea junto con
los sistemas de misiles balísticos
hipersónicos quintal destruyeron una
gran base de almacenamiento de
combustible y lubricante de las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas esta base era la
principal fuente de combustible para los
vehículos blindados ucranianos en las
áreas de operaciones militares en el sur
de ucrania
kim sal significa daga en ruso y aunque
en esta ocasión la ojiva del misil es
convencional tiene capacidad nuclear
evita las defensas antiaéreas es lanzado
es de un caza y se puede maniobrar la
trayectoria en pleno vuelo su concepción
parte de una serie de armas estratégicas
avanzadas por el presidente vladimir
putin en 2018 el analista argentino
alejando corbacho explicó en france 24
los posibles motivos de solución se
puede tener 22 explicaciones hasta el
momento la primera es que justamente
responde a emplear armas más
contundentes y más pasivas para obtener
un éxito rápidamente y otra explicación
en algunos centros de defensa están
ofreciendo la es que no se están
quedando sin munición este más menos
costosa está más estandarizada
el sábado ya fueron usados en el oeste
de ucrania en de latín para destruir un
almacén subterráneo en el que habría
misiles y munición de aviación por lo
que cuando se acerca el primer mes de la
invasión rusia está desempolvando todo
su armamento